i'm gonna level with you molly opioids
have a 97
relapse rate you have gone through this
15 times
do you know what an opiate antagonist is
no
it's a shot we give you once a month
this shot essentially makes you immune
to getting high
is it safe are you kidding me now all of
a sudden your body's a temple
you have to be clean for at least a week
four more days seriously
tired of what we've been through i'm
scared for you whenever she's around
who is that if i wasn't a junkie would
you even ask
probably not whenever i've decided to
re-engage with her i've always done it
with my eyes
wide open so you feel like
you've run out of home please i can't do
that yes you can
you want to give up the fight mom how is
she
she sits around smoking twitching
and i am there watching her like a hawk
and pretending that i'm not
almost one day down
three more to go
it's the end of the road i'm so sorry
wish i'd been around you should have
been you think it's my fault
that you're an addict
oh my god
it just goes on and i am so sorry
that my drug addiction is so incredibly
difficult on you sometimes i get the
feeling
i don't want to love her anymore
do you know how many times that i have
told myself that i'm not gonna steal
to get hot someday i want things to be
easier for her then i'm not going to
lose custody
of my children to get high when you
think
[Applause]
oh i believe it's not what does it take
to get c
[Music]
if there's anyone who has the strength
to break free of this
it's you i really believe that
i'm proud of you somehow
[Music]
you